>>
WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG SUNDAY"
$2 MILLION RAISED SO FAR FOR
MARINE LIEUTENANT COLONEL STUART
SHELLER WHO POSTED A VIDEO ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SLAMMING THE
BOTCHED AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> A TANK COMMANDER HAS THE
SIMPLEST COMPLAINT IF, BOOM,
FIRED.
BUT WE HAVE A SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE THAT TESTIFIED IN
CONGRESS IN MAY THAT THE AFGHAN
NATIONAL SECURITY FORCE COULD
WITHSTAND THE TALIBAN ADVANCE.
WE HAVE A CHAIRMAN OF THE JOINT
CHIEFS WHO HAS COME OUT AND
SPOKE TO MILITARY POLICY, WE
HAVE A MARINE COMBATANT
COMMANDER, ALL OF THESE PEOPLE
ARE SUPPOSE ANDED TO ADVISE, AND
I'M NOT SAYING WE'VE GOT TO BE
IN AFGHANISTAN FOREVER, BUT I AM
SAYING THAT ANY OF YOU THROW
YOUR RANK ON TABLE AND SAY, HEY,
IT'S BAD IDEA TO EVACUATE BAGRAM
AIRFIELD BEFORE WE EVACUATE
EVERYONE?
>> YOU KNOW, THE MONEY RAISED BY
THE FOUNDATION WILL GO TOWARD
POSSIBLE LOSS OF MILITARY
BENEFITS AND RETIRING LEGAL
COSTS ON TOP OF OTHER EXPENSES.
HIS PARENTS HAVE GONE PUBLIC TO
TALK ABOUT THEIR SON.
>> OUR SON, WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
OUR SON.
OUR SON IS A HERO.
HE FOUGHT FOR THIS COUNTRY FOR
17 YEARS.
THEY LEFT HUNDREDS OF AMERICANS
IN AFGHANISTAN WHERE THEY'RE
LEAVING OUR SON TONIGHT IN
PRISON, AND THAT'S NOT OKAY WITH
US.
AND I CHALLENGE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU?
>> WE WANT STUART SCHEEER
RELEASED.
WE WOULD LIKE HIM TO HAVE HIS
HARD-EARNED PENSION REINSTATE,
HIS MEDICAL BENEFITS THAT HE IS
GOING TO NEED AFTER THE
DEPLOYMENTS HE HAS ENDURED.
BUT IF THEY WON'T DO THAT, AT
LEAST RELEASE HIM AND LET HIM
OUT OF THE MA ENRADIOS. --
MARINES.
>> IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO HEAR
THAT X. A LETTER FROM GOP
LAWMAKERS TO THE MARINE
COMMANDER, THIS CONFINEMENT
APPEARS TO BE SIMPLY FOR
MESSAGING, RETRIBUTION AND
CONVENIENCE.
GIVEN HIS EXCELLENT RECORD AND
MORE THAN 15 YEARS OF DEDICATED
SERVICE, WE DO NOT BELIEVE AND
HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THE LIEUTENANT COLONEL POSES A
GREAT RISK OF CRIMINAL
MISCONDUCT.
YOU KNOW, IT JUST -- YOU TRY TO,
YOU TRY TO PUT YOUR HEAD AROUND
THIS, AND IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE.
YOU'RE ATTACKING, I GET IT,
INSUBORDINATION, BUT WOULDN'T
THAT BE JUST A TALKING TO?
WHY DO YOU THINK, AND I'M GOING
TO GO TO YOU FIRST ON THIS,
SEAN, WHY DO YOU THINK IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO QUIET ANYONE WHO
QUESTIONS THIS ADMINISTRATION?
>> BECAUSE YOU CAN'T HAVE
DISSENT, TYRUS, RIGHT?
I'M GOING TO READ YOU A QUOTE
FROM THE MARINES.
THE MARINE OFFICIAL SAID THEY
CONSIDER SCHELLER A FLIGHT RISK
AND BELIEVE CHINA MAY INTEND TO
USE HIS COMMENTS AS PROPAGANDA.
REMEMBER BACK EARLIER THIS YEAR
IN ALASKA WHEN BLINKEN MET WITH
THE CHINESE AND THE CHINESE WERE
USING BIDEN AND DEMOCRAT
COMMENTS AS PROPAGANDA TO CALL
AMERICANS RACIST?
THEY KNOW ALL TOO WELL ABOUT
PROPAGANDA.
AND THIS STORY, WHAT REALLY
FRUSTRATES ME IS THIS IS SOMEONE
WHO STOOD UP AND SAID IF I PUT
MY RANK ON THE TABLE, I'M GOING
TO INSPIRE OTHER PEOPLE TO STEP
IN AND IT THEIR RANK ON THE
TABLE AND ALL OUT THIS BOTCHED
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
NO OTHER OFFICERS STOOD UP, AND
THAT'S THE PROBLEM IN AMERICA.
WE ALL LOOK AT BRAVE PEOPLE WHO
WILL STAND UP AND IS RISK
EVERYTHING TO PUSH BACK ON THESE
POLITICS, BUT IF WE DON'T STAND
WITH THEM, IF WE DON'T JOIN THE
FIGHT, JOIN THE CAUSE, WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE TO THE WOKE
LEFTISTS.
MORE PEOPLE HAVE TO GET IN THE
FIGHT, AND IT'S SHAMEFUL THAT
MORE MILITARY MIN -- MEN AND
WOMEN DIDN'T JOIN HIS CALL.
SOMEONE ELSE SHOULD BE IN JAIL,
NOT ME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET ME PLAY YOU SOME NEW SOUND
FROM SCHELLER.
ROLL THAT.
>> I WAS THE ONLY OFFICER IN THE
ENTIRE AMERICAN COALITION FIRED
IN THE DEBACLE OF THE
AFGHANISTAN PULLOUT.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN FIRED.
HOWEVER, THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
GENERAL OFFICERS WHO ARE NOT
BEING HELD TO THE SAME STANDARD
IS A MICROCOSM OF THE ENTIRE
PROBLEM THAT IS GOING TO BRING
DOWN THE GREAT INSTITUTIONS OF
THIS REPUBLIC THAT WE LOVE.
>> JACKIE, YOU CAN SEE ONE SIDE
OF IT, YOU KNOW, HE SHOULDN'T
SPEAK OUT OF RANK.
BUT IN TERMS OF MESSAGING, DO
YOU REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
WHAT HE'S SAYING?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WHAT I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IS
THE FACT THAT HE'S THE ONLY ONE
GETTING FIRED.
LOOK AT THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THIS BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL.
WHY DOESN'T ANTHONY BLINKEN HAVE
ANY RESPONSIBILITY HERE?
HE SHOULD LOSE HIS JOB.
WHAT ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS?
SHE WAS THE LAST PERSON IN THE
ROOM WHEN THE DECISIONS WERE
MADE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
BEING ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED?
LEAVING AMERICANS ON THE GROUND,
ABANDONING AFGHAN PARTNERS WHO
HELPED US WHILE WE WERE THERE.
THIS IS REALLY A PROBLEM BACK TO
WHAT SEAN IS SAYING, THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO A CERTAIN
DEGREE TURNING US INTO THE CCP
IF, TURNING US INTO RUSSIA,
CONTROLLING THE MESSAGING AND
BASICALLY SHOWING PEOPLE YOU
WILL BE PUNISHED IF YOU SPEAK
OUT.
WHAT I'M REALLY PROUD TO SEE
HERE IS ANDY GALLAGHER, HE WENT
THROUGH A WHOLE TRIAL HIMSELF,
HE KNOWS HOW MUCH MONEY IT
COSTS, SO 27,000 DONORS, OTHER
VETS FROM THIS COUNTRY, OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL HAVE STEPPED
UP TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO HELP
HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR YOUR LEGAL
DEFENSE, FOR THE PENSION THAT
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY FROM.
THIS IS REALLY SAD, AND WE HAVE
TO FIGHT FOR OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH IN THIS COUNTRY, AND HE'S
DOING THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, AND I, I SAVED YOU
FOR LAST, LISA --
[LAUGHTER]
BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S COMING, IT'S
COMING.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THEY SAID WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE THEY WERE
CONCERNED CHA HE WOULD FLEE --
THAT HE WOULD FLEE TO CHINA AND
THEY WOULD USE HIS STATEMENTS AS
PROPAGANDA AS IF THEY DON'T HAVE
CNN IN CHINA?
I GIVE IT TO YOU.
>> YEAH.
HE DID THE ONE THING YOU CAN'T
DO WHICH IS SPEAK UP AGAINST THE
REGIME.
GO THROUGH THE THINGS YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO DO.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO GET 13 SERVICE
MEMBERS KILLED DUE TO YOUR
INCOMPETENCY, THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO DRONE AN
ENTIRE FAMILY INCLUDING SEVEN
CHILDREN, LIE ABOUT IT.
THAT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE MARK MILLEY, YOU'RE
ALLOWED TO ATTEMPT A COUP,
THAT'S OKAY, BUT YOU CAN'T SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THE REGIME.
JACKIE'S RIGHT, REAL COMMUNISM
IS TAKING HOLD IN AMERICA.
WE'VE SEEN IT THROUGHOUT THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS WITH COVID.
IT'S DESTROYING SMALL BUSINESSES
AND COMPANIES THAT ARE MORE
DECENTRALIZED BY WITH EMPOWERING
THE CENTRALIZED WHICH ARE THESE
BIG CORPORATIONS.
IT'S PAYING PEOPLE TO STAY HOME
AND BECOMING BEHOLDEN TO THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S THE VACCINE MANDATES, THE
DRIVING INDEPENDENT THINKERS,
CRITICAL THINKERS OUT OF THE
MILITARY AND OUT OF THE WORK
FORCE.
AND WHAT ALL OF IT DOES IS TO
BEAT PEOPLE INTO SUBMISSION AND
TO DESTROY THOSE WHO DARE NOT
SUBMIT.
AND THAT IS LIEUTENANT COLONEL
SCHELLER.
AND THAT IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO FIGHT BACK, AND
THANKFULLY PEOPLE ARE DONATING
AND MEMBERS OF CONGRESS A